what has happened and what we found out
through our observation I happen to be
involved in a management consulting firm
and our specialty is in knowledge
services what is happening as we talk to
men our clients into management as we am
there's been a consumer research in this
area what's happening is that in the
organization in the management of an
organization senior executives yes they
want those discreet disciplines they
want there to be a specialized library
there want there to be a records unit or
an archives unit or a publishing and
media department that sort of thing but
they also want that to be under the arm
or under the umbrella of one knowledge
strategy organization there they they
are looking for people with that they
can give titles to or he can do the work
of something called a director of
knowledge strategy or a CKO or a CIO
which we already know about or how about
the CLO the chief Learning Officer so
there are roles for people in this area
to get to those jobs will need people
who can work as knowledge specialists as
knowledge strategist as this is a new
one to me just in the last couple of
years the km Systems Manager I was just
saying - Larry we were both so surprised
recently to find out that in some
organizations the corporate intranet is
now being referred to as the corporate
km system so there are changes as Linda
said there are massive changes going on
in this in in the whole area of
management and we're the people who can
come in and and help work with them so
what are some of the so what what are
some of the opportunities that we have
out there well there are these there is
this thing that I'm referring to and
talking about a lot as the new knowledge
services we're having they I'd just
described a little bit of it to you
there are organizations out there that
are looking for this kind of leadership
management strength in the people that
they hire and as I say this is not an i
school program it's not a graduate km
program now the content of those pro
we'll definitely inform what we're doing
but this is something very very
different we are actually responding to
management needs so that management can
connect knowledge strategy with the
organizational or the court or the or
corporate mission or business strategy
so as graduates if you take this program
you spend 16 months with us and and you
take our core courses and our other
courses our electives what is what are
you going to be doing who are you going
to be well you're going to end up
working in what I like to think of as
the strategic knowledge field this
that's our profession its strategic
knowledge strategic knowledge management
if you want to call it that strategic
knowledge services if you want to call
it that the key thing is its strategic
to the organization I like to think of
your role is not so much as a strategic
knowledge professional but as the
knowledge thought leader for the entire
organization you're the person who is
going to be responsible or at least
leading the effort to facilitate new
ways of thinking to ensure that
information and knowledge flow
throughout throughout the organization
and is built-in to the work processes
you'll be capturing and connecting
content and and putting ideas and
translating ideas into practice you'll
work with ROI you'll work with
performance measures you'll work with IT
and ICT specialists all the time I mean
after all the whole knowledge domain is
run by or fits into what happens with
information technology these people
you're going to be referred to as a
systems thinker you're going to be a
content provider and you're going to be
what I like to think of as your best
role you're going to be a change agent
and knowledge gatherer if you take this
course in this program and you are in
this degree I think you'll be in the
upper echelon of the people in this
country who are leading knowledge
strategy I want to talk about a course
in business analytics and competitive
intelligence now the first part of that
might sound a little dry might sound
like something an accountant does
business analytics the second part might
sound a little oversexed it's
kind of got a James Bond ring to it with
the competitive intelligence piece
cloak-and-dagger operations black bags
and surveillance neither a true business
analytics actually right now is a very
important in emerging field the key
parts about it are being able to track
what most people are calling key
performance indicators watching those
things that mean a lot to your company
now if you're working for Victoria's
Secret it's going to be very different
those key performance indicators are
going to be very different than if
you're working for Nestle's or Nike or
General Motors but everyone has their
own set of key performance indicators
knowledge professionals are the ones
that actually help determine what things
count most the CEO certainly may want to
see how much silk is going across the
marketplace or the cost of a probe of
elastic if he's working for Victoria's
Secret but as a knowledge professional
you might be the one to tell him that
doesn't really count to you boss it
really counts to you are these three
things those performance indicators are
based on what you know means something
in the marketplace what things are
actionable what things are going to be
applicable to their daily business now
the information professional who has an
idea of what strategy is is plays a key
role here sometimes we're brokers of
information we know where information
can be had and obtained and fed into our
system sometimes were the people that
can talk to IT where other people can't
we're marketers and other strategists
can't we understand their language we
speak in terms of projects and we know
how to bring information out of our own
data sets and the key other thing was we
know where external data can be had and
we know what information can be brought
together in real time or what
information will be brought in quarterly
monthly annually now in the competitive
intelligence side I actually have to say
I have enjoyed saying that I work in
competitive intelligence when I'm at
cocktail parties
it sounds very intriguing it's a I am
nothing like a spy and I would not never
make a good one and in fact competitive
intelligence is really about above the
board and legal activities and the right
things to do to find out information
about what's happening external to your
organization not every organization has
a competitive intelligence function
you'll find it kind of integrated in
with strategic planning general business
planning new product development and a
couple other categories
to me competitive intelligence is really
about knowing what external information
exists and how to get it you've all
heard of the term SWOT analysis I'm sure
right it's kind of a fun term strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats
competitive intelligence is mostly about
the opportunities that your company
might have and the threats that it faces
from its competitors you're identifying
how those intimate information can be
analyzed and distilled to make something
actionable will be is the key to your
effectiveness and competitive
intelligence it's an outward focus
discipline and I think that if here in
the course that will teach it will be
about where those sources are and how
those sources can be brought to bear to
make an impact on your business
what percentage in your organization do
you spend on knowledge do you think
money non-capital good so not stuff
everything else what percentage do you
spend on knowledge what do you think
thank you yes go try it it turns out it
is about 60 to 70 percent in almost any
organization in the United States was
over a hundred people is spent on
knowledge knowledge gives meaning to
information it what it's what makes
information valuable without it is just
stuff knowledge it's what people know
and groups of people know and we're in a
dilemma that's why it's great to take
these classes and to take this degree
because our organizations in the US and
Japan and Western Europe and somewhat
Latin America are not built to work for
knowledge they're built to work for the
traditional sources of wealth land labor
and capital
they weren't structured originally for
knowledge and we still live with 19th
century models in a 21st century
knowledge economy Henry Ford who
probably epitomizes the industrial type
of model said why do I want to pay for a
workers head I only want his arm people
still believe that they may not use such
language but they still believe that our
organizations are based on command
control and hierarchy and fear when a
organization's first
came about in the 19th century the model
they used was the military command
control hierarchies and fear this does
not work for knowledge it worked fine
for land labor and capital the wealth of
the world has increased 17 times from
1880 to 2010 we are infinitely wealthier
than our great-great grandparents in
things we own in Technic at Wilson we
live longer but we work run our
organizations as if they were all like
Ford not all over the world it's
changing it's certainly changing in
countries changing someone in Brazil in
Africa some Asian countries but we still
do it in the United States so we have to
find new ways of organizing ourselves to
better exploit and explore how knowledge
works we have to find new ways of
working organizing work organizing the
organization so it finds new knowledge
it brings knowledge in it encourages
development of knowledge look at how
Google works if you want an example of
how this works
compare Google to Microsoft and you'd
see very clearly two different models
and who's more successful I'm going to
talk a little bit just quickly about the
program format this is a 16 month
program that starts in September and
then finishes up in the following
December the reason we chose 16 months
it's not a magic number this is based on
a lot of research out there on the
design of effective masters programs and
is really by design meant to encourage
your success in the program and your
completion of the program 16 months in
terms of the research is kind of magic
in the sense that if we can move
students through programs to the
targeted outcomes of the programs in
that time students stay engaged and they
generally graduate and do very well so
that's why we chose 16 months and that's
what the design of this program is all
about there are three residences in the
program one at the very beginning of the
program one at the end of this
in the second term and one at the
beginning of the final term during those
residences we have five days of
face-to-face intense interaction here in
the campus where we will do face to face
components of coursework where there
will be networking events with faculty
with other students and with invited
industry experts who will also be
talking and providing workshops during
that time there may be site visits
during that time to interesting
companies related to the different
courses that you'll be working in so
that's the residency component and then
in between the residences we have
courses online that will fill in the
gaps between our face-to-face moments we
are offering our online courses that are
part of this program on a cutting-edge
platform that we have developed that's
really meant to encourage easy access to
content and the best content possible in
terms of assisting your learning it is
framed by live sessions that will happen
every week through Adobe Connect
professional I'm sure some of you have
done web conferencing before anybody so
it's a very nice web conferencing
platform that's highly interactive and
that allows you to listen to lectures as
well as to break out into groups talk in
those groups and come back into the
larger lecture similarly just in the
same ways that you would in a
face-to-face classroom it's just through
through online so there's a live
component of our online experience and
there's a very social component of our
online experience if you were Mary
Anderson this is showing you all of the
stuff that's that the latest stuff
that's going on in your classes so if
there are discussions going on in your
classes or if your faculty members have
posted announcements or if folks in your
class are tweeting about something in
the class it will show up here and you
can go directly to those posts so
basically you'll move through courses
unit by unit in the central part here
whatever your
looking at in unit 1 there might be like
video lectures here there might be
access to software that you're using in
the course there may be readings etc all
of the readings will be accessible
either you can buy the book so you can
download them into the system there's a
very nice reader that can be read on
almost anything a new can iPad etc so
it's it's pretty cutting edge in terms
of the delivery of content also on the
side where you see again there's a
newsfeed of student interactions going
on in the course discussion forums etc
those needs news feeds hook out into the
profiles of your fellow students so you
can click on those profiles and learn
about where your fellow students are
coming from
they also click out to immediate access
to live chat and to Skype so it's kind
of a communication portal through which
you can contact your fellow students
which is really nice especially in
courses where there are team projects
etc that you'll be working on
I have a question with regard to the
interface and actual digital experience
for classrooms here are communicate
visually I was interested to know
whether we as students can communicate
through visual or video conferencing
with the actual professor in addition to
conversing with students outside of
class yes so I the way that the online
courses work is they will have X number
of large group live sessions with the
faculty and the TA and those sessions
will remind you of face to face
classroom sessions in the sense that
there will be lecture it may be that we
pre produce some of those lectures you
watch them for homework and then it's
more of a Q&A session
the faculty can put you in breakout
groups bring you back you can present to
the rest of the students in the class
whatever ever you've done if you've been
working on an excel sheet or if you've
been writing something together etc so
that's what those live sessions look
like well we have we have the school of
continuing education
first of all you have access to the the
University Career Services office but we
also have in our school a an in-house
Career Services office that is designed
specifically to deal with the special
needs of the students and our programs
because our programs are different quite
different from some of the other
programs in the university in that
they're professional applied programs
for the most part so you will have
access to those services certainly when
you're on campus they'll be here for you
and we will be working on on ways to
make those available to you across
distances also
the capstone the capstone project
focuses in two particular areas one in
using one aspect of your current work to
develop an idea to explore an idea that
you might not be able to at the
workplace so using the workplace as as
the foundation for your capstone project
or to look at something that you want to
get into so a whole new area that you
want to want to explore I mean we have
had people who've done that and actually
did land jobs in these areas in the
digital asset management area for
example so it was something they wanted
to explore and they were able to
actually use that that experience to
explore new near new career options and
develop an expertise that they didn't
have before is there the question is is
there any difference between si CIOs CKO
CTO and I also mentioned CLO chief
Learning Officer there has been there
has been but one of the things that
we're noticing and very much in the last
couple of years
I'd say last three or four years is that
there is a great melding of this and as
I mentioned earlier in our a lot of the
work that I I'm involved in with is this
area called knowledge services which
converges information management
knowledge management and strategic
learning the learning you need for the
knowledge sharing in the organization
what we're finding in companies and
organizations is that this is merging
together and that's why I gave that
example about the the corporate
internets now in some places being
referred to as the corporate km system
knowledge seems to be the maybe it's
temporary we don't know but it sort of
seems to be the the the word that all of
these different disciplines these these
discrete disciplines i've been referring
to they seem to like to be merged
toward the knowledge construct why that
is we get into it a whole semantic
discussion about what goes on in the
language and that sort of thing
but we're seeing a lot of direction in
that area so my answer to you of my
response to your question would have to
be there has been in the past
differences between the CTO a CIO se
Cayo CLO but we are now seeing those
merge closer together and then as we get
into an or an organizational position
like a director of knowledge strategy
that's going to be in charge of all of
those discrete disciplines if you look
at LinkedIn and look at the kind of
titles that are built around terms like
business analysis look at knowledge
management or knowledge officers and
look for intelligence either business
analytics for business intelligence
experts and you'll see the kinds of jobs
that are out there today now they're
going to fall in a couple different
continuum groups among the consultancies
for example there are knowledge experts
and they tend to be industry focused
knowledge experts within industry
verticals their job is not really just
to be the smartest person in the room
about cars or about apparel their job is
really to hold the information that the
knowledge that's already known things
that have already been written by the
organization so that they will reinvent
the wheel every time the consultancy
operation comes in it's also to capture
the knowledge of the individuals much in
along the ways of what Larry was talking
about to know who when the organization
knows what what and what they know and
there's become new ways within
Internet's where people are capturing
knowledge and expertise from the people
that are in their staff so that there's
something institutionalized about that
especially which is very important so
okay so the the program design is that
you take in the beginning of the fall
session you have this four-week
intensive course that has 12
instructional hours in during the
residency then there's a short break
then you have a 10-week session during
which you have two courses and then
there is a longer winter break then
there's another 10-week session during
which you have two courses and then
there's a fairly
Spring Break and then there's a
four-week session where you have one
course that also has 12 hours of
face-to-face instruction in the
residency when you move into the summer
that's when you're in the elective zone
you choose two electives during the
summer we'll have a list of electives
that are associated with the program but
of course in the school we offer many
electives we are also putting lots of
other courses in other programs online
so I mentioned our business courses so
depending on your purposes the topic of
your capstone project the outcomes
you're targeting as a student post
program there are elective options in
the summer